elle soutient des gens je vais te dire
je trouve un petit reportage dans la rue
et les gens ted et je suis sûr que ça te
ferait plaisir de savoir que les gens
dans la rue était de tout coeur avec toi
dans ton c'est par là tu vas voir
voici costard de stars
maintenant trois quatre ans cela dit
c'est très dur et on va l'encourager à
une parachutée on a besoin de
témoignages d'anciens alcooliques dit
que vous buviez énormément et qui est
maintenant c'est complètement arrêté de
boire et elle n'avait jamais rechute et
pour l'encourager à ne pas rechuter
d'accord dire ça parce qu'on a besoin
des gens et personnes venues lui dire
quoi non non vous mettrez un cache sur
les yeux un nombre écouter excusez moi
mais je suis pas alcoolique vois pas
pourquoi je veux raconter des choses
comme ça pour une émission le fou je
veux dire je tourne monsieur vous avez
arrêté le voir depuis combien d'années
est pas arrêté de boire je n'ai jamais
vu j'ai quand même une belle tranche de
pochtrons monsieur au montage on coupera
on dira que vous êtes alcoolique
combien de litres de vin par jour à 3
litres et demi j'avais encore des
séquelles aujourd'hui un petit peu et un
petit peu je tiens encore de je tremble
un peu d'accord des fautes de goût
immonde genre écharpe verte sur terre et
bleue
oui encore pas content enfin content du
tout vous dites parfois c'est dur je
suis tenté de boire un petit coup dur et
parfois c'est dur je suis tenté ça
m'arrive de temps en temps quoi faire la
scène là où il allait j'ai gueulé dans
le coin pour montrer les fléau de
l'alcoolisme
alessi messieurs
images terribles qui je l'espère et
d'orange à cannes plus jamais boire une
goutte d'alcool
c'est l'affectif deux ans deux ans et ce
sont les alcooliques unanime qui m'ont
aidé les amis m'ont pas aidé la
littérature m'a pas aidé baudelaire ne
va pas aider puisqu'il dit il faut
toujours être ivre de vin de poésie ou
de vertu ball un bout de l'air doit
lancer le poète j'ai plus de souvenirs
charles baudelaire la littérature
française mon dieu quel conseil
donneriez-vous à jacques dutronc pour
qu'il arrête définitivement de bois
avant qu'il ne refuse jamais de penser
qu'il est jacques dutronc qui l'a
sûrement déjà fait des choses difficiles
moi j'ai pas vu son van gogh qui pensent
à van gogh van gogh les draps on va
faire la scène de la rechute vous faites
semblant devoir
voilà mélangeant les choses en ont fait
semblant voilà l'image d'une rechute
terrible et oui il en met partout c'est
pathétique
ouais laurent baffie
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu